hemos usado las integrales definidas
para encontrar áreas lo que quiero hacer
ahora es ver si podemos usar la integral
definida para calcular la longitud de
arco y qué quiere decir eso bien si
iniciamos en este punto sobre la gráfica
de una función y terminamos en este
punto no sobre una línea recta
ya sabemos calcular distancias sobre una
línea recta más bien sobre la
trayectoria de la gráfica de la función
esta es la longitud que queremos
calcular queremos calcular la longitud
de ese arco así es que esta es la
longitud de arco en este caso va a ser
desde que x es igual a a
hasta que x es igual a la longitud a lo
largo de esa curva y cómo hacemos esto
una de las cosas que hemos aprendido con
el cálculo integral es que cuando
tenemos algo que está cambiando como
esto siempre podemos dividirlo en partes
infinitamente pequeñas que podemos
aproximar con segmentos de rectas o con
rectángulos para luego tomar la suma
infinita de esas infinitamente pequeñas
partes déjame entonces dividir todas
longitud de arco en infinitamente
pequeños tramos que podríamos llamar
secciones de arco y estas secciones de
arco al ser infinitamente pequeñas las
voy a llamar de s de s
obviamente los estoy dibujando mucho más
grandes de lo que son para que tengamos
una idea clara del concepto de
diferencial de arco y para qué dividimos
la longitud de arco en estas secciones
diferenciales bien ese de ahí es un de
ese y si aquí tenemos con este otro
color otro de ese y por acá tenemos otro
infinitamente pequeño cambio en la
longitud de arco si sumamos si tomamos
la suma infinita de todos estos veces
vamos a obtener la longitud de arco así
es que la longitud de arco es igual a la
integral de d s estoy sumando todos esos
veces a lo largo de la longitud de arco
lo cual denota mos de esta manera pero
esto así como está no nos sirve pues
está en términos de de ese y nosotros
hemos trabajado con de equis y de que
veamos si podemos expresar esto en
términos de d
y deje de nueva cuenta si esta sección
es infinitamente pequeña podemos suponer
que es un segmento de recta de la misma
manera como pudimos aproximar áreas con
rectángulos tomamos infinitamente
pequeños rectángulos que al hacer su
suma infinita nos daba el valor del área
aunque la región original no fuera
rectangular aquí estamos haciendo lo
mismo tomando estas aproximaciones con
rectas infinitamente pequeñas pero al
tomar la suma infinita van a
proporcionarnos la longitud de arco así
es que si suponemos que este es un
segmento de recta voy a tratar de
expresar lo en términos de de x y
entonces esta distancia de aquí es de x
es un cambio infinitamente pequeño en x
mientras que esta distancia de aquí es
de g es importante aclarar que no
estamos dándole un tratamiento riguroso
a los diferenciales simplemente queremos
entender cuáles son los conceptos que
hay detrás de la fórmula de longitud de
arco aquí podemos ver entonces qué de
ese basándonos en el teorema de
pitágoras se puede expresar en términos
de de x al cuadrado y al cuadrado es
decir de s
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de de x al
cuadrado más de g al cuadrado así es que
esta integral la podemos reescribir como
la integral
en vez de escribir de ese vamos a
escribir la raíz cuadrada de de equis
elevado al cuadrado
de x elevado al cuadrado
más
del elevado al cuadrado de nueva cuenta
esto sale directamente de aplicar el
teorema de pitágoras y esto empieza a
ponerse interesante ya lo escribí en
términos de xy de ye pero están elevados
al cuadrado dentro de una raíz cuadrada
que pueda hacer para simplificar esto de
tal manera que podamos integrarlo bien
puedo factorizar de x al cuadrado vamos
a escribir esto entonces como esto es
igual a la integral de la raíz cuadrada
de x elevado al cuadrado de x elevado al
cuadrado que multiplica a uno más de iu
sobre de x elevado al cuadrado
esto lo mismo que tenemos arriba si
distribuimos de x elevado al cuadrado
aquí obtenemos exactamente esto y ahora
podemos sacar de x al cuadrado del
radical así es que esto es igual a la
integral de la raíz deja de mantener el
mismo color para el radical la integral
de la raíz cuadrada de 1 más vélez en de
x que ya sabemos que es la derivada de
la función de jane de x elevada al
cuadrado y si sacamos de x al cuadrado
del radical la raíz cuadrada de x al
cuadrado es de x simplemente es
de x simplemente es de x esto es
interesante pues sabemos cómo calcular
esto entre dos límites podemos tomar la
integral definida entre aire pues ahora
estamos integrando un número infinito de
de equis estamos ahora integrando con
respecto a x para todos los valores
entre x iguala y x igual a b tomemos la
suma de los productos de esta expresión
por de x y está básicamente es la
fórmula para la longitud de arco es la
fórmula para calcular la longitud de
arco y aunque parece complicada en el
próximo vídeo veremos que es fácil de
aplicar
aunque la matemática puede ponerse un
poco peliaguda esta fórmula también la
podemos escribir con otra anotación esto
lo puedo escribir también como la
integral desde hasta ve desde que x es
igual a hasta que x es igual a de de la
raíz cuadrada de 1 más en vez de de jane
de x ponemos f prima de x
efe prima de x elevado al cuadrado
de x así es que si conocemos la función
conocemos fx calculamos la derivada de
esa función f prima de x la elevamos al
cuadrado le sumamos 1 sacamos la raíz
cuadrada de eso y entendemos con
respecto a x desde que x igual a hasta
que x igual a b haremos eso en el
próximo vídeo